have you filed your taxes yet if so
Congrats you've done more than some of
the biggest multinational corporations
who have armies of accountants lawyers
and lobbyists to help them avoid taxes
the US has the highest corporate tax
rate in the world at 35 percent but most
of the country's biggest companies
aren't just paying a lower rate they're
not paying federal taxes at all they
even get refunds here are just four of
the worst offenders remember 2008 the
worst financial crisis since the Great
Depression
it took a near trillion-dollar taxpayer
bailout to rescue Wall Street from its
own mistakes corporations like Citigroup
on the verge of collapse were saved but
instead of returning the favour'
Citigroup aggressively moved to protect
its earnings from taxation by taking
advantage of tax credits exemptions and
moving cash overseas where it can't be
taxed Citigroup has over forty three
billion dollars parked in offshore
accounts in places like Bermuda and the
British Virgin Islands and with that
they've avoided paying almost 12 billion
dollars in taxes in 2014 when you look
at your monthly cell phone bill you
might think damn these selfies eat a lot
of data but you should remember that
Wireless companies like Verizon are
notorious for dodging corporate taxes
between 2008 and 2013 Verizon made over
40 2.4 billion dollars in US profits but
instead of paying taxes on those profits
it received a refund from the IRS
totaling seven hundred and thirty two
million dollars over five years
the company also stashes billions of
dollars in offshore tax havens to avoid
paying us income taxes and it's all
legal and if that's annoying to you just
remember NSA data collection doesn't pay
for itself now does it a profit shift
today keeps the auditors away well
that's what Apple hopes but it hasn't
exactly worked the company which made
182 billion dollars in revenue last year
has been the subject of investigations
in multiple countries as to the lead
of its tax schemes one is profit
shifting apples favorite by which you
move profits overseas to say Ireland
where it enjoys a tax rate of 2% this
has partly helped Apple avoid an
estimated 74 billion in US taxes from
2009 to 2012 move eight point two
billion out of the reach of the
Australian Tax Office and evade nine
hundred and sixty two million in Italian
taxes Mamma Mia
it's no surprise that Boeing strong-arms
the tax system it's the second largest
defense contractor in the world and it's
known for pitting States against one
another in bidding wars to win jobs
whoever offers the biggest tax breaks
and has the weakest union laws wins in
2009 Boeing moved the production of its
new planes from Washington State to a
non-union plant in South Carolina the
National Labor Relations Board called
the move punishment for striking
Washington workers South Carolina gave
Boeing nearly 900 million dollars in
incentives including tax breaks then in
2013 trying not to fall out of favor
with its sugar daddy Washington State
gave Boeing the biggest tax break in
state business history eight point seven
billion dollars so do you have to be a
tax evader to be a job creator